hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger et gainsbourg avait
déchiré à billets à 7 sur 7
et alors il paraît que j'ai fait très
bien ça c'est ce que gagnent et ça c'est
ce que l'état me prend je suis un
insoumis
voilà ses salutations et et ça bien sûr
c'était ça bon on a bien fait c'est ma
folie robert volut probert talking to me
plaît le plus grand imitateur du monde
savez vous imitez maintenant le chien
enragé je le crains jean-luc je le
crains moi aussi je sais ce que vous
êtes prêts à vous l'offrir en voulez
vous
[Applaudissements]
tendez ou au niveau de ta carrière
mathieu delahousse à imiter personne
johnny dans ce rallye si oui ç'a eu ces
données
[Applaudissements]
il était quelqu'un vous tarde un peu à
les faire brûler au franc réf
c'est bon c'est bon on a compris c'est
une catastrophe ça un sachet imiter
maïté deuxième temps ce qui s'est fait à
l'imitation des règles alors oui thierry
moreau c'est quoi ah les huiles
on essaie de trouver un nom pas non plus
le regard man 2006 et jean michel maire
n'ont pas de pad homme politique n'a ni
même que les animaux le phoque
à côté on a l'otarie à faire quoi vous
allez y on chope hpc de fer victoria
abril d'accord c'est en fait très bien
le co qui paraît à we can parce qu'on
m'a dit allez
[Applaudissements]